hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in article 6 of question 46 of the
sumatia logia Prima sekunde Thomas
Aquinas is going to be asking some
really important questions in
considering arguments about two emotions
that we sometimes confuse with each
other and we really need to distinguish
anger on the one side Ira in Latin and
hatred odium on the other side and the
question is is anger something more
serious in in the Latin gravior than
hatred and the you could say the subtext
behind this serious in what sense
serious in being more bad or evil right
which of them is you could say Mali or
which of them is a greater malam a
greater bad thing within the person who
is feeling them a nice suppose you could
also say in general in how it plays
itself out and there there's some
arguments that he's providing this is a
very interesting article because it
typically Thomas will raise you know
some counter arguments to his own
position which is that anger is not as
serious as hatred it's not as big of a
problem
and he you know rattles off three of
these and then he spends a significant
amount of time discussing each of those
after he's given his own position so the
responses to the arguments are really
fleshing out Thomas's own position in
ways that isn't always the case in the
somote so what what are the three
arguments the first one is he says it
seems anger is more serious than hatred
why he brings up a Biblical uh text from
Proverbs anger has no mercy nor Fury
when it breakth fourth right so it's Ira
known
habitm is Mercy or compassion you could
even translate it as so anger doesn't
have this and Proverbs the biblical text
is saying that and he says hatred
sometimes permits or allows has
mercy so therefore anger is more serious
so because anger doesn't show Mercy
anger is badder than hatred so that's
the first one the second one this is
very uh interesting case being made here
it is worse both to suffer potty right
to have evil imposed upon you and to
grieve over evil or he also brings up
distress dolor is the term used there
which can translate either of these and
so the idea is that for the person who
is being affected hatred is really just
interested in the other person suffering
evil like you kill them right and now
they don't feel anything
anger wants the other person to suffer
and to know that the angry person is the
cause of their suffering like Thomas
says for an angry man it's not enough if
a person does suffers evil he insists
the object of his anger be conscious by
it and be distressed by it and so he's
deriving this from Aristotle right so in
this case anger does the same thing as
hatred but then it puts something else
on top of it that makes it worse so that
that's an interesting contention and
then finally the third one
anger is more stable more durable it has
greater lasting capacity why because
anger is derived from multiple causes
right so he says when more factors are
required to establish something once it
is constituted once it's set up right
then it seems more stable so a habit
acquired by repeated acts is more
durable anger is created by as he says
concurrent causes other emotions right
hatred isn't hatred is kind of a pyramid
motion and so anger is more stable than
hatred is which means that it's worse
right so a stable Badness is going to be
worse than a Badness that can go away
Thomas doesn't think any of these are
right he thinks that anger is less
serious why well he starts out by
talking about the the object of these
emotions the objectum right and he says
that the the object allows us to assess
pensant right to weigh both the identity
the the species and the uh the nature
the razio the account of an emotion and
so what is it that anger and hatred are
after in one sense they they're kind of
the same right both anger and hatred aim
at imposing something bad on somebody
else okay so in that respect they're
very similar to each other
but why
what is the the point of it so in hatred
you hate the thing that is hated that is
odious to you because you view it as
evil or harmful you know noxious uh
damaging to you and so you naturally
hate it right so uh you know we could
have all sorts of silly hates who I take
the bitter medicine I'm like oh he hates
it right and you do because you don't
like the bitterness of The Taste if you
actually were smart you wouldn't hate
the medicine because it's making you
feel better right but you know imagine a
child or I hate taking medicine
um
anger
is also oriented towards doing something
bad to somebody else imposing bad upon
them
but it's got a different reason
so he says anger is directed against the
one who has provoked it hatred intends
evil desires evil right uh appetite so
intend or desire both work for this
hatred intends evil as such per se it
wants evil as evil for what it views as
an enemy and so
um you know he'll talk about this as
applying evil for evil per application
Mali right you see the other person as
as a kind of class that you hate or kind
of thing that you hate and then you try
to you want to destroy it you want it to
not exist
anger's a little bit more complicated
especially morally speaking why because
anger as he says
aims at or desires uh you know the evil
but not as evil just for its own sake
um evil as good under a certain aspect
so how does that work evil and good are
contrary right well anger views the evil
that it's imposing as in a certain
respect a good thing it doesn't think
that it's good as such right uh punching
somebody in the nose is generally bad
but if they punched you in the nose and
you're going to get your just
Vindication and you punch them in the
nose you're doing something bad that
turns out to be good and good in what
respect so here he uses two very
interesting terms he tells us that they
regard the evil as just eustom right and
as now it's translated here as
vindictive but you should say
Vindication right uh here Vindication
um so it's it's
the right uh kind of suffering that's
being imposed on the other person and he
talks about his pure application bony
admalam you impose
something good to the bad right and or
as the bad you could say so he says that
the desire for evil for the sake of
justice is clearly less evil than to
will evil to somebody absolutely the
person who's angry might be confused
about whether their cause is just but in
their mind they actually they're not
saying I get to punch people or do
things get you know angry turn tables
over just for its own sake I do it
because I think that in a certain sense
it's the right thing to do it's the
right thing for me to do to this person
not to just any random passerby so this
means according to Thomas Aquinas that
although anger is still doing evil it's
doing evil you could say in a certain
sense for good at least potentially
right whereas hatred is just bad right
it's it's really evil for its own sake
and he actually says something very
interesting here the desire for Evil
under the aspect of Justice can be
inspired by this virtue of Justice
so getting angry imposing penalties on
other people could be the right thing to
do and even stem from virtue within you
if it be tempered by the dictate of
reason if reason is running the show so
you can be angry and reasonable at the
same time angry says fails in this only
when it doesn't obey the directive of
reason and pursuing revenge like you you
do it the wrong way or it's got
spillover effects on other people or
you're too
um
too intense in your revenge seeking or
you impose it too long all these sorts
of things that go into assessing anger
uh that Aristotle brought up Thomas
Aquinas is bringing up as well now what
is his response to the first argument
anger doesn't show Mercy hatred does
show Mercy
um you know Aristotle himself who Thomas
Aquinas is relying on significantly says
that this is a big difference between
anger and hatred although it goes the
other way anger is sometimes willing to
show pity or Mercy or compassion hatred
does not
and so he says
um
Mercy is more likely in Anger than
hatred why because hatred Wills evil to
another as evil and therefore no amount
of evil will satisfy it I mean Aristotle
says that
what hatred really wants is the other
person not even to exist to not have
being and so hatred can go very very far
it's not going to show
compassion or be limited by that anger
however is for something a bit more
specific it wants to go up to a certain
point and you know he says anger seeks
evil only by way of just Revenge when
the evil inflicted exceeds the measure
of justice as he sees it so the angered
person is seeing that they went too far
now they can feel bad they can feel pity
or Compassion or Mercy Misericordia for
the person that they have now hurt too
much right if somebody says something
mean to you so you go and you punch him
in the face and they fall down and they
hit their head and you know start
bleeding all over the place you're like
oh crap I didn't mean to go that far I'm
really sorry right and can do that
whereas hatred will be like
I hate you so die you know so that's
that's an interesting point the first
argument turns out to be completely
backwards
and we see something kind of similar in
the second part right so the second
argument is hatred and anger both desire
harm to the other person that they
suffer some some evil but anger wants to
put something on top that the person is
aware of who's doing it and that they
feel that suffering in the process and
Thomas says well that's not really going
to make anger worse why
it says vengeance is gotten by
inflicting punishment which of its very
Nature's contrary to the the will the
will of the other person right who's
being punished uh painful and imposed
for for some fault the one who is angry
wants the one who is punishing to be
aware of it and suffer and realize his
suffering is in retribution for the
wrong which he's done so in a certain
sense what the angry person wants is not
that the other person actually suffer
evil for its own sake just that they
suffer so that they can be aware of the
fact that they did something wrong and
are being punished for it it's really
the punishment that the person is after
the angry person
and hatred just wants to do something
bad something evil to impose something
evil on the other person and you don't
care whether it's painful or not because
all you know ideally you'd want them to
die you'd want them to go away you'd
want them to be erased or eradicated so
again
um the prioritization
it turns out to be off base
um the third one is similar
Thomas is going to point out that
um
what is produced by several different
causes is more stable when the causes
are of one kind one cause can be more
influential than many others and he says
the cause of hatred is more persistent
than anger why because the cause of
hatred is this Viewpoint that something
else is evil and harmful so you know so
long as you see things that way you are
going to keep hating it right and you
know you could change it if you come to
realize oh it's not it's not actually a
bad thing the example of the medicine
realizing that the medicine is not
something hateful or odious but rather
something beneficial for you now you
stop hating it right but he says that
anger arises from a mental disturbance
brought about by an injury and
um because of this anger passes more
quickly than hatred right and this is
why he says Aristotle says hatred is
more in cure durable than anger so you
know we we get angry we feel angry we
feel these different you know things
that are part of it pain or sadness
pleasure Delight hope all of this stuff
is going on and then you know we get
angry we retaliate against the person
and all these things go away the Clauses
are gone through the retaliation and now
we're not angry anymore right whereas
with hatred you see something as bad
you're going to keep seeing it just as
bad and want to destroy it so as it
turns out hatred is worse more serious
gravior than anger according to Thomas
Aquinas who as I've pointed out is
drawing pretty heavily on Aristotle here
but going a little bit beyond what
Aristotle has to say and I think one of
the really key takeaways from this
section is the realization that what
anger is doing is is deliberately
imposing something bad or evil on
another person but viewing that very
imposition as something good because it
is just or proper retribution could be
wrong about that but that's the way the
person sees it and so for Thomas that
that means that anger is in a certain
sense a little bit more in tune with our
our human nature less of deformation of
it than is hatred